this was mayar's family home before last
Wednesday when a category 5 hurricane
hid aapo Mexico's Pacific Coast Resort
town and reduced it to this she and 11
other relatives survived by hiding in
this
passage we were 3 hours in here it
flooded it was halfway up our legs it
was horrible there were
children much of aapo is now devastated
80% of the hotels are down DED but mayfa
Echoes many when she says the
authorities have yet to help
them we want the government to be here
and to support us it's been a week and
they haven't shown up they have
abandoned
us where mayfa lives on campee Street
the residents themselves have begun the
cleanup
operation we're all helping each other
as neighbors as family because we've
never faced a hurricane as strong as
this one there's no electricity yet on
campee street just like vast sectors of
the rest of the town and a lack of food
and water too here like elsewhere that's
led to looting the Sho in campi street
has been looted just like almost every
other convenience store and supermarket
in aapco and that means that a week
after the hurricane you can't find
anything to eat or drink in this town
even if you've got the
money the president's promised a more
than $3 billion Aid package he says that
in 3 months families are going to have
food and money to pay damaged household
appliances additional security is also
part of the plan but the residents in
campee Street say the National Guard
already sent to aapo haven't shown up
here they barricade themselves in at
Sunset frightened of
looters no one comes in not Cars not
people we close off the streets at 7:00
p.m. and open at 6 in the
morning in a town that this week has
spiraled out control they're having to
rely on themselves John Homan alzer
aabo make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer